[Music]
on this Tuesday night Tit for Tat
Beijing Avengers Canada's expulsion of a
Chinese Diplomat we understand there is
retaliation but we will not be
intimidated what the Chinese government
might do next anger in Alberta this
election is nothing but a distraction
calls to postpone the provincial vote as
wildfires rage the verdict is in for
Donald Trump the former U.S president's
punishment in a civil sex abuse and
defamation suit
National with Donna Friesen reporting
tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us the Chinese government is hitting
back announcing the expulsion of a
Canadian Diplomat in Shanghai the Tit
for Tat is a direct response to Canada
ousting a Chinese Diplomat who was
accused of trying to intimidate
conservative MP Michael Chung
allegations Beijing has denied China's
retaliation was widely expected but
there are fears of more repercussions to
come more on that in a moment but we
begin in Ottawa where the House of
Commons was consumed by debate over why
the Trudeau government didn't act sooner
Mackenzie gray has tonight's top story
the retaliation was almost immediate
12 hours after Canada expelled a Chinese
Diplomat Beijing fired back declaring
Jennifer Lin Lalonde a Canadian working
in the Shanghai consulate persona non
grata we understand there is retaliation
but we will not be intimidated and we
will continue to do everything necessary
to keep Canadians protected from a
foreign interference that protection was
required after assisa's report stated
conservative MP Michael Chong and his
family were targeted by Xiao Wei a
Chinese Diplomat based in Toronto
because Sean spearheaded calling out
beijing's treatment of the uyghur
minority this is a decision we took
seriously we took with careful
consideration in order to uh to do the
right thing and expel the the Chinese
Diplomat China's reaction viewed as
proportionate this was a reciprocal
result of the Canadian decision to expel
the Chinese Diplomat the Prime Minister
said he didn't know about the briefing
until he read about it in the Globe and
Mail but Chong says the current national
security advisor has admitted to him
ceases share the top secret document
with Justin Trudeau's then National
Security advisor but who that person was
and why they didn't tell the PM still
isn't clear all three National Security
advisors Justin Trudeau had in 2021 say
they haven't seen the Chong report
Vincent Rigby saying he left a job
before the report was published and both
David Morrison and Mike McDonald do not
recall having seen any material
regarding threats against MPS while on
the roll foreign adversaries do try to
sow divisions both Morrison and McDonald
still serve as senior civil servants
with Morrison being sent last week to
summon the Chinese Ambassador over the
trunk story bottom line is here we've
got a prime minister who doesn't know
what's going on in his office that
should be a concern to every Canadian
MPS May compel those three advisors to
give more answers as the conservatives
are looking to have them appear before a
House of Commons committee studying
foreign interference Jeff McKenzie Ray
in Ottawa thanks Mac the Chinese
government has hinted at further
retaliation saying it will react firmly
and hold up its interests so what could
that look like Mercedes Stevenson joins
us now so Mercedes what might China be
considering here
Jeff Beijing is not a government that
makes knee-jerk decisions they are
strategic and they have a long memory
the question that they will be asking
themselves now is just how harshly they
want to respond and what is in China's
interests there are three major options
if China does decide to retaliate
further the first would be against
Canadian agriculture and natural
resource products the second would be
using their military to saber Rattle and
the third would be retaliation against
Canadian citizens who are in China on
that first one of economic exports in
2022 Canada's exports to China were a
record 28.7 billion dollars coal mining
pulp Mill Productions and oil seed
farming are Canada's top three exports
to China and one of those was previously
targeted when China blocked the Imports
of Canadian canola that move came in
2019 after Canada detained among Wong
Zhou Beijing claimed at the time that
they had found pests in the canola a few
months later China accused Canada of
foraging eat certificates and blocked
those Imports too China is such a
massive economic power that trade
retaliation can have a significant
effect on the Canadian economy that
Leverage is exactly what China often
relies on to deter countries from taking
action to protect themselves from
beijing's influence or intimidation but
the question will be whether or not it's
worth it for China in this case do they
need to appear strong or do they want to
contain the damage and move on when it
comes to saber rattling the Chinese
military has aggressively buzzed
Canadian Military Intelligence aircraft
in the past our military now trains
specifically for that and would be
prepared if China did it again and we
have Canadian aircraft and a Canadian
ship that are scheduled to be in the
Pacific in coming weeks few of the
sources I spoke to thought retaliation
against Canadian citizens in China was
likely the scale of humiliation for
China is seen in this case as being much
less than when the RCMP arrested Mong
Wong Joe all of my sources said one
thing in common Jeff China is hard to
predict but the hope is that this ends
with a diplomatic expulsion tit-for-tat
some pointed out that Beijing is facing
a different situation with the
International Community here harassing a
lawmaker or their family is strongly
frowned upon and that might play into
beijing's PR plan
so much potentially at stake here
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes
China is a member of the United Nations
Human Rights Council and now Canada is
making a play for a seat Ottawa is
bidding on one of three spots for the
period of 2028 to 2030.
there is a clear backlash happening
around the world as we speak when it
comes to Human Rights and we just can't
stand Idol just screaming from you know
the sides saying basically that we
should be doing something without
rolling up our sleeves and getting
involved
Canada's six main priorities include
protecting human rights Defenders and
freedom of religion so far Canada is up
against Greece for a spot the vote is
expected to take place in 2026.
Vladimir Putin marked Russia's Victory
Day commemorating the defeat of the
Nazis in the second world war with an
angry speech accusing the west of
unleashing war against Russia the
remarks come nearly 15 months after the
Russian president launched a full-scale
invasion of Ukraine and just hours after
yet another major attack Russia launched
25 missiles at Targets across Ukraine
including the capital Kiev nearly all
were intercepted and no injuries were
reported this year's Victory Day
festivities in Moscow were overshadowed
by Russia's losses on the battlefield
Redmond Shannon reports
one date May 9th with two names in
Russia it is a Victory Day a celebration
of the Soviet Union's defeat of Nazi
Germany an event Vladimir Putin
regularly compares to his current war
against Ukraine which he falsely claims
is led by a Nazi regime
a real war is once again being waged
against our homeland Western Global
Elites are provoking bloody conflicts
and coups sowing hatred and russophobia
some Victory Day events across Russia
have been scaled back this year that
after the apparent drone attack on the
Kremlin last week
in Moscow there were no fly paths and
instead of a modern Fleet of Tanks
trundling through Red Square just one
relic of the second world war those
newer units seen here last year likely
deployed on the front lines in Ukraine
particularly in the months-long battle
to try and take bakmut
the head of Russia's Wagner mercenary
group has again suggested he may
withdraw from the ravaged Ukrainian City
unless his men get more arms he posted
more cryptic rants against Moscow
leaders timed to coincide With Victory
Day commemorations
but in Kiev May 9th is no longer a
Victory Day the occasion is now shifting
to May 8th President Vladimir zielinski
welcomed the head of the European
commissioner Ursula Vander Lyon he says
his country will join EU Nations by
instead observing the ninth as Europe
day and let me walk
day it is a celebration of post-war
peace in Europe but the two allies are
preparing for more
warenski thanking the EU for its promise
of 1 million artillery rounds and
pushing for his long-term goal of
joining the block
on a date when Ukraine has normally
glorified the Red Army it now instead
looks West to the yellow and blue of
Europe Redmond Shannon Global News
London
turning to the wildfires in Alberta now
where thousands remain out of their
homes tonight much needed rain is
helping firefighters in some parts of
the province but more scorching
temperatures are expected in the coming
days as Heather York's West explains
Ottawa says more help is on the way
a lifetime of memory sits in Ruins on
the ground when Carol Johnston saw what
was left of her home on the East Prairie
metis settlement she collapsed
devastating that's my life the fire was
on their back door we had no money
at least 14 homes were lost to the
wildfires here as the community assesses
its losses there is palpable anger as
well anger the mayor of Yellowhead
County shares when this fire situation
started this whole entire County was
tender dry
Wade Williams says it took five days of
fighting with officials before a
provincial fire ban was put in place a
delay he blames on the Alberta election
this election is nothing but a
distraction at this point when we
the albertans need every government
official to roll up their sleeves and
fight for this province before we don't
have a province to come back to rain in
some parts of the province has helped
with the fire fight and the remaining
evacuation orders in Yellowhead County
are expected to be lifted in the coming
days but soaring temperatures are
expected to return by the weekend which
is why fire officials are pleading for
help we haven't had enough rain to
completely impact all of the fires it's
been doing a great job and darkening
them down and helping with the
suppression but it's not enough to say
that they're out or they're under
control
Alberta has asked Ottawa for support
from Canada's Armed Forces the minister
of Public Safety says Personnel will be
deployed soon too late to help those who
have already suffered losses but
Alberta's unprecedented Fire season is
far from done Heather York's West Global
News Yellowhead County Alberta
and smoke from those Alberta wildfires
has spread all the way to Ontario making
for a particularly hazy Skyline in
Toronto and even reaching parts of
eastern Ontario now there are no air
quality concerns however because the
smoke is high in the atmosphere
Ontario's marine land is under renewed
scrutiny after a beluga whale and
bottlenose dolphin died at the Niagara
Falls theme park the province's
solicitor General's office says a team
is still working to determine the cause
of deaths which could take several weeks
just two months ago kiska Canada's last
remaining captive killer whale also died
at that facility Ontario's Animal
Welfare Services has been investigating
the Park's water quality and Marine
Mammal care since 2020.
the fight to avoid a financial meltdown
coming up the high-stakes standoff
between the U.S president and his
Republican Rivals plus the verdict is in
for a former commander-in-chief in a sex
abuse and defamation case
and protests in Pakistan after a former
prime minister is arrested in dramatic
fashion
[Music]
welcome back we are just weeks away from
an event that could Rock Global markets
and destabilize the American economy the
U.S government reached its debt ceiling
earlier this year effectively running
out of money it needs to borrow more but
raising the debt limit requires
cooperation from Republicans who are
demanding drastic spending cuts
President Joe Biden refuses to negotiate
and time his running out Jackson prosco
reports on Washington's high-stakes
Showdown
they meant to try and Stave off economic
disaster Mr President can you cut a deal
in time but the U.S president and his
Republican opponents are still miles
apart on a deal to raise the debt
ceiling the limit on how much money the
US government can borrow I asked the
president this simple question does he
not believe there's any place we could
find savings this can cost almost 8
million jobs if if House Republicans get
their way it could also lead us to a
recession trigger a recession if the
ceiling isn't raised the government
could run out of money as soon as June
1st leaving no way to fund the military
social programs or payments on 31
trillion dollars in debt held by Foreign
Nations I think it's widely agreed that
this would be a huge hit to the economy
and really an economic catastrophe the
bill is passed Republicans have offered
to raise the limit in exchange for deep
spending cuts President Biden refuses to
negotiate we're trying to hold the debt
Hostage to us to agree to some Draconian
cuts
the standoff alone risks rattling
markets the last near default in 2011
saw the U.S credit rating downgraded
anytime we skate close to the edge
you're rattling the cages you're saying
hey hey pay attention this could really
happen this time around it really could
experts believe the risk of a worst case
scenario could compel a last minute deal
I think the global financial markets
would melt down they will always find a
way to increase that debt ceiling
because they recognize what would happen
if they were to go over that Cliff still
the White House insists it's seriously
concerned about the risk of breaching
the debt ceiling and says backup plans
are in place in the words of top
officials none of the options are good
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
a jury has found Donald Trump liable for
sexually abusing and defaming an advice
columnist the verdict was announced in a
federal courtroom in New York City on
the first day of deliberations the jury
found Trump sexually abused e Gene
Carroll 27 years ago then defamed her by
branding her a liar the nine-member jury
awarded Carol about 5 million U.S
dollars in Damages
strange verdict
um this was a rape claim it was a rape
case all along and the jury rejected
that but made all the findings so
um we'll obviously be appealing those
other findings
Trump won't face any criminal
consequences because this was a civil
case it's another legal setback for
Trump as he campaigns to retake the Oval
Office in 2024.
and to some breaking news tonight
Republican Congressman George Santos is
reportedly facing federal charges it's
not yet clear what the charges are but
the first term representative of New
York has faced investigations into his
personal and campaign finances as well
as complaints alleging sexual harassment
multiple U.S media reports citing
unnamed sources say Santos is expected
to turn himself in tomorrow morning at
which point the charges will be made
public
[Music]
wild weather still ahead torrential rain
floods New Zealand's biggest city
foreign
major flooding has triggered a state of
emergency in Auckland New Zealand's
largest city streets there are swamped
causing widespread delays emergency
crews have responded to more than 200
calls involving landslides falling trees
and trapped cars further north a high
school student is now missing suspected
of being swept away while exploring
caves with a school group Pakistan is
blocking social media platforms and
restricting internet service in the wake
of violent protests over the arrest of
former prime minister Imran Khan
dozens of paramilitary forces and
armored vehicles detained the 70 year
old and then drove him away he was
appearing in court on charges of
corruption the dramatic arrest sparked
violent demonstrations across Pakistan
by his supporters Khan was ousted as
prime minister just over a year ago and
has been campaigning for early elections
ever since he denounces the accusations
calling them part of a politically
motivated plot by his successor
foreign
strikes in densely populated areas of
the Gaza Strip killed three senior
militants according to Israeli officials
Israel's Army released footage of the
bombings which it says targeted leaders
of an Islamic Jihad militant group
involved in recent attacks on Israel
Palestinian Health authorities say at
least 10 civilians including women and
children were also killed in the
overnight strikes setting the stage for
what is likely to be a new round of
heavy fighting in the region thousands
of mourners turned out for the funeral
procession for the victims
and that is global national for this
Tuesday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
year Canada is goose spit Park in Comox
British Columbia thanks for watching
nithu gotcha will be at the anchor desk
with you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]